hey guys welcome back to brainy video  we're back on foreigner and today we're  gonna be showing off the executions  emotes Eggman signatures for the new  hero in season nine black prior just  thought I'd show it off I am using the  test build this is recorded weeks ago is  by the time you're seeing this but I  decided I might as well use it anyway I  probably could have easily done it with  the actual build that comes live on the  31st the date of this video goes live  but I thought I'd just do it anyway from  here so I don't make my time a lot  easier of course Nate Ubisoft for even  allowing me to use this test build this  isn't a sponsored or an ad video as the  one I posted before but this one is just  gonna be showing up executions emotes  and signatures so let's get started like  to be if you do enjoy then which one was  your favorite I'll see you in the next  one guys peace out